The latest "Fantastic Beasts" film might just
hold more secrets than Dumbledore himself.
Do you want to learn more about the deluminator,
or clever references to the previous films?
Keep watching to see the small details you
missed in "Fantastic Beasts: The Secrets of Dumbledore."
What is a wizard to do without a bird to save
the day?
Go back to 2002 when "Harry Potter and the
Chamber of Secrets" premiered.
Fans had just met Dumbledore's phoenix Fawkes,
who played a significant role in Harry destroying
Tom Riddle's diary and saving Ginny.
Fawkes carrying Harry, Ron, Ginny, and even
Lockhart out of the Chamber even made it onto
the cover of the American version of the book.
Now, with the events of "The Secrets of Dumbledore,"
phoenixes are more integral to the plot than ever.
However, it's not a phoenix that offers the
"Chamber of Secrets" Easter egg.
Toward the beginning of the movie, Newt faces
off against Grindelwald's followers.
Mirroring the Fawkes scene from decades later,
a dragon-like creature called a Wyvern flies
Newt, his suitcase, and his beasts away from
the area as it puffs up like a dragon pufferfish.
It's a significant homage to Fawkes — who
might just be Credence's phoenix.
There's no denying that Sirius Black is one
of the greatest characters to appear in the
"Harry Potter" books and films.
But he's also deeply misunderstood.
Here is a man who's had his reputation obliterated
by a supposed friend and was tortured in Azkaban
for 12 years.
Yet despite his deep trauma and the overwhelming
depression he sometimes faces, Sirius Black
still manages to be a good person.
"We've all got both light and dark inside
us.
What matters is the part we choose to act
on."
But between his wisdom and sadness, Sirius
has an unparalleled zest for life and an infectious
yearning for mischief.
He's everything Grindelwald could be if he
wanted, but the budding dictator chooses to
kill people instead.
Much of the third "Harry Potter" book and
movie hinges on the manhunt for Sirius, with
Hogsmeade, Diagon Alley, and Hogwarts littered
with moving Wanted posters.
Now "The Secrets of Dumbledore" is giving
fans deja vu with
Grindelwald's snowy Hogsmeade wanted signs.
However, Grindelwald is exonerated for the
crimes he committed, while Sirius must go
into hiding until his death.
Even in the wizarding world, life isn't fair.
Who needs flying cars when you can have magical
trains?
Some of the "Secrets of Dumbledore" references
to "Harry Potter" are pretty on the nose,
but it doesn't make them any less charming.
While the Wizarding World films often focus
on the beauty of humanity, they also encourage
fans to appreciate the breathtaking beauty
around them in nature.
The idea for the Hogwarts Express came to
J.K.
Rowling as she rode on the very train that
inspired her to write "Harry Potter and the
Sorcerer's Stone."
And in its way, the Express gives new students
to Hogwarts a glimpse of magic before they
even raise their wands for the first time.
"The Secrets of Dumbledore" had a similar
idea, when Newt's ragtag group of misfits
meet on a train while it flies through snowy
mountains.
It may be a fairly plain-looking train, but
the homage to the Hogwarts Express is palpable.
Dumbledore is known for his sage wisdom, and
even 50 years younger than his first appearance
in the "Harry Potter" universe, he doesn't
disappoint.
The future headmaster has gone through more
than a few internal struggles and successfully
fought off a lingering thirst for power.
"With or without you, I'll burn down their
world."
Dumbledore has long since ditched the "for
the greater good" mantra he lived by in his
time with Grindelwald, but he still occasionally
falls into that mentality.
The most devastating example of this kind
of lapse is his secretive training of Harry
to prepare him to take down Voldemort.
He went through with this risky plan knowing
full well that Harry might not survive the conflict.
Despite his many flaws, Dumbledore gives Harry
some food for thought after Cedric's "Goblet
of Fire" death.
"Dark and difficult times lie ahead.
Soon, we must all face the choice between
what is right and what is easy."
Of course, he's had a long time to perfect
the sentiment between the events of "The Secrets
of Dumbledore" and "Goblet of Fire."
He gives Newt a similar message to relay to
Vogel, who holds Grindelwald's fate in his hands.
So, what's the message?
"Do what is right, not what is easy."
Later, answering the question of why Grindelwald
can run for Supreme Mugwump despite being
a wannabe dictator, Dumbledore says,
"Because Vogel chose easy over right."
Apparently, Dumbledore was a bit pithier in
his youth, but the sentiment is the same.
In "The Deathly Hallows," Grindelwald and
Dumbledore's previous obsession with the fabled
relics of the Peverell brothers comes to light.
Not only was Grindelwald on the hunt for the
Elder Wand, the Invisibility Cloak, and the
Resurrection Stone, but Dumbledore found himself
on this quest for power as well.
Until this point in the series, Grindelwald's
Hallows obsession goes relatively unmentioned
beyond the reveal that he obtained the Elder
Wand from esteemed wandmaker Gregorovitch.
Yet it looks like the Hallows may play a greater
role in Grindelwald's continued quest for
domination over the muggle world.
In "The Secrets of Dumbledore," fans learn
that each wizard running for Supreme Mugwump
has a symbol associated with them.
Wizards cast their vote for the next leader
by firing off their nominee's symbol from
their wand.
In a blink-and-you'll-miss-it scene, it's
clear that the Deathly Hallows symbol inspired
Grindelwald's mark.
The Hallows symbol lies in the middle of two
Gs, with a more pronounced Elder Wand nestled
distinctly in the middle.
Along with the Hallows reference, the symbol
is eerily similar to the Death Eaters' Dark
Mark, right down to the lime green color.
Though attacked by his werewolf professor
and discovering that his best friend was sleeping
with a 40-year-old rat, Harry's most traumatic
experience in "The Prisoner of Azkaban" might
be when his Care of Magical Creatures book
tries to eat him.
When the students call out Hagrid for his
bizarre choice of biting books, the giant
defends himself.
He calls the books cute and instructs the
students to "stroke the spine" to prevent
their textbook from attacking.
As it turns out, the wizarding world isn't
quite finished with "The Monster Book of Monsters."
When Dumbledore's army sets off to confuse
Grindelwald and get the Qilin to the election,
all but one group member carries a bewitched
suitcase that looks like Newt's.
Amongst other things, one has a golden snitch,
another has pastries, and yet another melts.
Of course, there's also one with colorful
textbooks.
Some of the titles include "Sonnet of a Sorcerer,"
which jinxes readers into speaking in limericks forever.
Then there's "Have a Fiesta in a Bottle,"
and "Extreme Incantations."
But alongside the colorful creations is the
dreaded "The Monster Book of Monsters," which
means that Harry's textbook is quite old.
It may have even been released before Newt's
book "Fantastic Beasts and Where to Find Them."
If there's one thing the "Fantastic Beasts"
series doesn't need, it's romanticizing Severus
Snape's creepy behavior toward Lily Potter.
In "The Deathly Hallows," fans learn about
Snape's obsessive "love" for Lily through
Snape's memories.
Sure, Snape turned his back on Voldemort,
but only after the dictator killed Lily — Snape
was fine with her family getting killed, as
long as she survived.
Snape's pining over the woman who turned him
down decades ago is endless and ridiculous,
to the point where he bullies her child (just
because Harry looks like James).
When Dumbledore asks if he loves Lily after
all this time, the potions master responds:
"Always."
This is stalker behavior, but even Harry himself
romanticizes Snape's actions when he names
his second son "Albus Severus."
In "The Secrets of Dumbledore," following
the reveal that Credence is Aberforth's son,
it's unclear why Aberforth never bothered
to look for him.
When Credence finally meets Aberforth, he
asks, "Did you ever think of me?"
Paying homage to Snape, Aberforth says, "Always."
Aberforth tells Credence to come home, only
taking responsibility as a father when his
son is dying — and there's nothing that
can save him.
In some ways, Snape and Aberforth are alike
- and not in good ways.
There's no better title for the third installment
of the "Fantastic Beasts" series than "The
Secrets of Dumbledore."
It turns out the future headmaster of Hogwarts
is harder to read than a hexed poetry book.
His instinct is to keep everything to himself
until the moment when he needs his allies' help.
"Dumbledore's got a real sort of checkered
history of being able to encourage people
to do crazy things."
The upshot of this is that he has a wealth
of knowledge about the wizarding world that
he keeps quiet, along with more than a few
wickedly powerful gadgets that he either procured
or created himself.
One such gadget takes the form of a stopwatch.
The first "Harry Potter" book describes it
as,
"A very odd watch.
It had twelve hands but no numbers; instead,
little planets were moving around the edge."
Dumbledore uses it to tell time, and it makes
an appearance in the first and fifth books.
However, it never shows up on screen until
the "Secrets of Dumbledore."
Here, Dumbledore clearly uses the pocket watch
to find Credence's location, and he has a
picture of the wizard on the stopwatch.
It's no surprise that the mysterious-looking
watch would have a use beyond telling time.
But it's unclear if it works to track down
just anyone, or if it's a Dumbledore heirloom
specifically made to keep tabs on his bloodline.
Either way, it's fun to see an aspect of the
book come to life on screen for the first time.
The wizarding world is chock-full of secret
passageways and unique ways that the magical
community separates their world from the muggles.
For instance, Hogwarts has a protection spell
that causes muggles to see a danger sign atop ruins.
When it comes to the entrance to Diagon Alley,
Hagrid shows Harry how to enter without apparating
or using floo powder.
He simply taps a combination of bricks, and
the wall opens up.
We haven't seen this method of entry in any
other magical location since then, but "The
Secrets of Dumbledore" brings it back when
Dumbledore's original army goes to the German Ministry.
The bricks are just a tad bit sleeker, but
the process is the same.
Cockroach clusters are peanut-type candy made
of, you guessed it, cockroaches.
These bizarre "treats" are purchased more
often to troll unsuspecting Hogwarts classmates
than to actually eat and enjoy.
Ron fails to trick Fred into eating them,
and as it turns out, the Slytherins in "The
Secrets of Dumbledore" have a similar idea.
When Jacob hangs out in the Great Hall, some
"nice" Slytherins offer him candy.
After Dumbledore declares that he never cared
much for "Cockroach Clusters," Jacob glares
at the mischievous Slytherins.
Despite Dumbledore's distaste for cockroach
clusters and earwax Bertie Bott's, he chooses
"Cockroach Clusters" as a password for his
office about 50 years later.
Maybe he just misses his Muggle friend.
Movie fans were introduced to the world of
"Harry Potter" when Dumbledore used his deluminator,
a light-sucking magical object of his own
making, to darken Privet Drive.
For a while, it seemed like the object's only
use was to suck up and release the light from
various light sources.
Then in "The Deathly Hallows," Ron inherits
the deluminator from Dumbledore.
Not only does the object control light sources,
but it seems to be a listening device, too.
After Ron bails on Harry and Hermione during
their Horcrux search, he hears snippets of
conversations from the object when Harry and
Hermione mention his name.
Even weirder, it acts like a Portkey to apparate
Ron back to his friends when he realizes leaving
was a mistake.
"So I took it, clicked it, and this tiny ball
of light appeared."
The full extent of the deluminator's powers
is never fully explored in the original books
and movies, but "The Secrets of Dumbledore"
provides some insight into the device's capabilities.
Dumbledore uses it in his battle with Credence
and later Grindelwald, where the object does
something very peculiar.
It seems like the deluminator takes both sets
of dueling wizards to a parallel plane adjacent
to the real world, but it looks like a darker
mirrored version.
It seems like people on the physical plane
can't see what happens during this duel.
However, one thing's for sure: The deluminator
has quite a few tricks up its sleeve — and
so does Dumbledore.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.